[Music]
hey what is up guys mpbhd here and yes
first things first we have already made
a video about all the things we think we
know about iphone 8 all the rumors all
rounded up in one place so the things we
think we might know the things we may
not know some really interesting stuff
in there i will leave that linked below
but this
this is taking it to the next level so
this has happened before but this is a
model uh actual physical in-hand
representation of all of these leaks and
rumors and everything we know about the
next iphone and what we're expecting of
it so this is something like what case
manufacturers might get their hands on
to start to design their iphone 8 cases
and start to prototype their iphone
accessories this is all the physical
dimensions and everything based on what
we know uh so thanks to sony dixon again
for helping us get our hands on this but
i figured i'd get a little bit more in
depth with it since we actually have one
now so right off the bat first thing
you'll notice of course is the display
which has some really awesome edge to
edge action but also has some
interesting top sensor protrusion going
on coming down from the top you may have
seen this in the latest leak where the
homepod firmware had a little bit of a
silhouette developers found that
represents the next iphone and it has
this indentation at the top for these
front-facing sensors it looks a little
bit weird in the glyph but seeing it in
real life this is what it would look
like and honestly still looks a little
bit funky but now that you see how the
display kind of wraps around that bar
with the rounded edges everywhere it
still looks really interesting reminds
me of the renders of the essential phone
actually which we have also yet to see
in person but obviously if this is what
it looks like my biggest question is
what apple plans to do with the software
you know will they put stuff up there in
the top corners maybe battery to to one
side the signal strength to the other
side and then notifications in the
middle whatever they do it'll be really
interesting to see but obviously the
bigger story with this model is
literally the screen to body ratio this
has always been a weakness of the iphone
it's 2017. bezels are shrinking the
iphone has had a massive forehead and
chin and even side bezels forever iphone
7 plus had a 5.5 inch display this year
but is still one of the biggest phone
bodies on the market this iphone 8 model
has what measures up to be a 5.7 to 5.8
inch diagonal but in a smaller body so
this is a big deal for the modernization
of iphone design for sure smaller body
more handheld more pocketable so thanks
to some after effects magic this is what
the display on the front of the iphone
might look like when it's on with ios
11. again not really sure
exactly what they do with the status bar
up top we played around with this for a
bit but you can see it gets a lot closer
to that 2017 feeling of just holding a
display in your hands will it be more
breakable and fragile because of this
design you know getting closer to the
corners of course but let's be real it's
probably worth it and people are kind of
breaking their phones anyway so now for
some other quick things you may notice
about this body number one is the glass
back so the iphones up to this point
have had these metal backs which of
course feel and look super premium but
of course don't support wireless
charging wireless charging doesn't work
through metal this iphone 8 model has a
glass back very similar to what we've
seen in samsung phones like the galaxy
s8 and note so you can support wireless
charging
but keep the metal on the sides and
still keep that premium feel in the hand
the other thing is the camera bump on
the back is of course still there it's
pretty big but of course this is what
we've been seeing for months now and
leaks about the new iphone new
orientation for the camera sensors flash
in the middle in between them and
hopefully these new cameras get a spec
bump to go with that big camera bump uh
and take some more awesome photos and
videos with this new year the power
button on the side is something i
noticed it's in the same place but it is
a little bit bigger which is interesting
because of the rumor that apple might
try to stick a fingerprint reader in the
power button this year since they
couldn't get it to work under the
display in time but the most recent info
suggests that this will be a normal
power button and apple will go all out
with 3d facial recognition for unlocking
your phone securely allegedly that can
be just as safe if not more so than a
fingerprint but you already know i'm
going to be testing that and then yeah
just the overall premium look and feel
of this model it's way nicer than early
renders obviously just like it ends up
being every year the glass even kind of
has this 3d curve right at the edges
sort of melts into the side rails so
it's smooth around there it's smooth to
hold but that is pretty much it and
honestly this is as close as we're gonna
get to seeing the next iphone short of
someone actually leaking the phone in
person but uh let me know what you think
is this something you would rock in 2017
and 2018 as iphone 8 maybe share this
video with your friends who are
interested in seeing what iphone 8 will
look like but until then that's been it
thank you for watching talk to you guys
the next one
peace
[Music]